the most horrifying story i probably
i've ever seen in the news we've been
talking about it for a couple days this
live action
story about how uh in dc there were five
babies who were killed through abortion
and now a whistleblower brought these
bodies that were photographs taken a
pro-life activist
broke the story
and and so the authorities are of course
in investigating the pro-lifers they're
letting the abortions off the hook
they're investigating the pro-lifers
it's not just five babies by the way
this has happened
well over 100 times
and they've only got evidence of the
five they've only got physical evidence
of the five well turns out live action
has a clip of the abortionist this
butcher who committed these atrocities
and
this goes back years now and he admitted
that he was allowing in violation of the
law allowing babies who were born alive
simply to die take a listen
obviously you're here for a certain
procedure and if your your pregnancy
were let's say you went into labor the
membranes ruptured and you delivered
before we got to the termination part of
the procedure here you know then we
would do things we would we would not
help it
yeah it would be you know a person that
would be a terminal person in
the hospital and say they had cancer you
know you wouldn't do any extra
procedures to help that person survive
they had like do not resuscitate orders
okay you know we would do the same
things here okay whereas if you were in
in a hospital in in virginia let's say
and you went into labor and you went to
the hospital and then they they saw you
deliver they would do everything
possible to help that
fetus survive okay but you won't we
wouldn't
yeah we wouldn't do it you know the
thing that all the hospitals do because
that's the law we don't do that here
you know how they help the fetus survive
even if you're going to use a silly word
like fetus instead of baby people say
fetus because they don't want to admit
that a baby in the womb is a baby the
fetus quote unquote stops being a fetus
by any definition once he's out of the
womb so then what he's saying is we
wouldn't help the fetus survive he's
saying we wouldn't help the baby survive
so do that here he talks about all this
poor woman she went to the hospital once
because her abortion didn't work out for
her and then she gave birth to the baby
and they wouldn't let her kill the baby
this guy this guy how many times has he
done this
it's it
it's almost funny if not for the
incredible suffering involved it would
almost be funny how ghoulish this guy
sounds his name is dr cesare santangelo
you probably haven't even heard that
name dr cesare santangelo
this guy we talk about vladimir putin
vladimir putin's butcher he's committing
war crimes sure we talk about people
like bashar assad the dictator in syria
he's a butcher he's committed work
rhymes sure
cesare santangelo is is just as bad
probably worse because he's focusing all
of it on innocent little babies that's
his job that's how he makes his money in
violation of the law he seems to know it
stone cold psychopath the guy should at
the very least be locked up for the rest
of his life frankly i would recommend a
harsher punishment from the civil
authority than that and this name this
name no one even knows his name you
should be posting this name you should
be publicizing this name cesare
santangelo
the worst killer the worst serial killer
murderer
in this country right now
who knows who knows how many victims
he's got maybe the worst in american
history
shine a light on that there are all of
the entrenched powers are trying to
cover it up cover up for this psycho and
trying to to bury the bodies actually
trying to incinerate the bodies without
even doing an autopsy don't let him get
away with it i'm glad you like that
cliff now
subscribe ring that bell get the
notifications better yet subscribe to
the michael knowles show on apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]